we have in our Studios Tom Friedman the
Foreign Affairs columnist of New York
Times and author of all is flat Tom
welcome back great to be here you named
your book world is flat came out about a
year ago other than the fact that he has
sold 1.5 million copies and it has been
on the New York Times bestseller list
for 45 weeks what else has changed in
the time since the book came out well
you know one of the things I've enjoyed
most Stein is it first of all just
thinking about why did this book catch
on you know after all it's book about
globalization somewhat technical in some
cases and I've really spent a lot of
time asking myself you know what what's
going on here as I said I'd like to
think it's because of my mellifluous
voice and beautiful brown eyes but I I'm
not that stupid so I know that I caught
a wave 9 and so what was it what was
that wave and I guess the best way I
could summarize it is that it's a wave
of anxiety it's a wave that basically I
would describe like this our parents
were sure that they were gonna live
better than their parents and they were
just assure that we their children we're
gonna live better than them our
generation is now coming to retirement
worried that we may not retire as well
as our parents and you know what our
kids may not live as well as we do and I
think that anxiety that anxiety that we
are now being touched by people who
never touched us before we're competing
with people who we never competed with
before and fortunately we're
collaborating with people we've never
been able to collaborate with before but
for all those reasons there is a wave of
anxiety out there that there's a lot of
things changing a lot of traditional
boundaries are being eliminated
competition is much more intense and
gosh I wonder if my kids are gonna live
as well as me what is what is ahead
things are changing so fast it's a fear
the unknown 9 and I say the known
because it's a fear of what people see
is real competition now coming from
corners that they've never seen it
before coming into the white-collar
realm not just the blue-collar realm
where we
we've become used to it and not knowing
where it stops okay the call center
operator well that's not important but
but my radiologist is now you know using
outsourcing to have x-rays read
somewhere my my accountant you know is
now drawing or can now draw on someone
in India to do accounting so suddenly so
many more things seem to be able to be
digitized automated or outsourced where
that stops or starts I think there's a
lot of people concerned in judging by
the reaction you got in the Silicon
Valley have been almost ready to profit
there how do you see the elect us high
tech companies and justing to this flat
world well you know the good news is
everything I learned about the flat
world I really learned from companies I
learned from CEOs and CIOs and CTOs who
were doing it but they two things were
happening that one is they were doing it
because no one who wanted to talk about
outsourcing and it's one of the kind of
reasons I walked into a vacuum on this
book and intellectual vacuum is that the
people who are doing it and boy they're
doing it and they're doing it at the
cutting edge and thank goodness because
they're really driving American
competitiveness of companies forward
nobody wanted to talk about it so one of
the fortunate things I was able to do
was to go in and get them to talk about
it and then kind of put it all together
and that really related to another point
and I think the book you know caught on
a little in Silicon Valley each one was
doing it but in his or her realm in
their own dot but nobody was really
connecting the dots and it always struck
me not you know when someone like
Michael Dell invited me to come to Delta
to talk about the book to his management
team and my attitude was you you talking
to me is there someone behind me you're
talking to me you meant you want you on
me to come to talk to you no no and and
I realized then you know from that
experience that even though they were in
the middle of it a lot of they actually
hadn't gotten outside and therefore when
I because I was just talking to all of
them across the spectrum and then kind
of put it all together
they found that actually both useful and
formative so those two things really
came together for me
other a group of people I think have
been very troubled by your book is this
education startling analysis I'm hearing
from people that they're extremely
ordered right as to what does this flat
world mean for us education system what
what the thing is going to happen there
well you know if I've gotten feedback
from any group any single group more
than any other is from American
educators school superintendents
teachers and whatnot all of whom you
know sense that we're not really staying
at the cutting edge that we are getting
this competition and everyone now
strategizing about it this it's actually
quite exciting that there's an
incredible amount of experimentation
going on in education in America today
I'm actually an optimist I'm actually
much more optimistic today than when you
and I talked about the book a year ago
because I see the reaction not just to
the book but to the moment that the book
describes is not one of triumphalism
where we'll be okay it'll all be fine no
no it's whoa the sky is falling good
that's good this guy actually isn't
falling you know it's not that bad but
that's good the reaction has been
immediate it's been energetic and has
been mobilized and so what I've seen in
going out to schools is tremendous
amount of experimentation about what is
the right approach to improve our math
science fundamentals to get more young
men and women into math and science
and so what I've done is I'm now
updating the book will be a 2.0 version
of the book out in in mid-april and it's
just expanded and and updated basically
and what I focused a lot in this book in
the new version is what I call on
education on what I call the new middle
that is we knew what the old
middle-class jobs were well I would
argue that in the flat world with
certain things being outsourced and
digitized we now really want to think
about what are the new middle job
because there's we need a middle class
so what will be the jobs of the new
middles so what I really did this last
year and it was go around to American
companies and say who works here him
over there
does he do she looks like she's got an
interesting job what's she up to and
after enough of this I basically
distilled down to eight categories what
I call the categories of the new middle
and these aren't specific jobs you know
you know widget operator here you know
it's sort of broad categories but the
end these will be the broad categories
of the new middle I'll go through them
very quickly for you one is great
collaborators okay when so many more
things are going to be made in global
supply chains the ability to be a great
collaborator to be able to work across
culturally and multinational II it's
going to be a huge number of jobs around
managing and coordinating these global
supply chains second are great leverages
people who can leverage technology so
one person can do the job of twenty
rather than competing with India where
or China where twenty people might do
the job of one so you you make up for
the labor cost by leveraging technology
third are great explainers boy there's
gonna be a whole industry in explaining
because there's enormous complexity out
there so whether you're a teacher a
manager a journalist the ability to
explain this complexity is going to be
in huge demand for that would call great
localizers look localizers are people
who can localize the global what does
that mean they can take the power of
this global platform and turn it into a
local business that's everything from
the ebay entrepreneur mom-and-pop who've
never started a business on ebay to the
garage owner in New Haven who goes
online one day and says to his partner
hey Bill
did you see this we can get our hub cabs
for half price from Romania half the
cost of what it gets would take to get
us from Rochester so they're leveraging
the global platform there by localizing
that global be a huge industry in that
fifth I would say are going to be people
who are great adapters ok people who can
basically stay one step ahead of the
forces of digitization and automation
and that's going to apply to a lot of
people in a lot of industries six would
be people who are
what I would call passionate
personalized errs if you can bring real
passion and a personal touch to any
vanilla task there's going to be a job
for you in the flat world seventh I
would call anything green and I mean
anything green and there is a job for
you
in the 21st century because green
technology is going to be the industry
of the 21st century so those are some of
the categories that I'm looking at no I
think the education part of think what
you mentioned is it's not only the
United States from heart I gather India
which is acclaimed as providing tens of
thousands of engineers every year India
is showing anxiety that it's education
system is falling behind and recently
you are in India so what did you find
about in the education system
who is interesting I was that NASSCOM
the Indian high tech Association's
annual meeting and full of some of the
brainiest most innovative people in
India but the buzz the subterranean buzz
I found there was really all about what
was me basically we're now doing a lot
of BPO that's India specialty Business
Process Outsourcing
that's everything from answering your
phone to writing your software to
running your back room your Human
Resources Department a good business but
India is getting competition and that
field now Vietnam will come in there
Eastern Europe they've got to move they
know to kpo
knowledge process outsourcing where you
you don't just tell me I don't just do
the how I do the what I actually
conceive of the project the idea and
then I execute and implement it to do
that though you need a different kind of
mindset you need a mindset that's
questioning that's innovative that's
synthesizing and Indian Education has
been very good for pounding in those
fundamentals we know that nobody does it
better
it's been great at getting people who
know how to do the how but it has not
been great for creating people to know
to ask the what and or the why and of
course the
the strength of the United States we
need more people and good fundamentals
they need more people who are creative
and that's where you're getting this
kind of grand convergence so I think
you're gonna see over time it loosening
up of the rigid Indian education system
and and introducing a lot more what and
why into the classroom because the
talent is there we know it's just really
how you shape it and reshape it from
what created it exactly to promote more
synthesis and creativity ya know the
flat world that you described courses is
getting flatter by the day but at the
same time I see a couple of some new
trends one of them is as we've seen
China attempted to raise cyber walls
right to still carve up the flat world
yes in a way that goes against the grain
now the recent development involving
Microsoft Yahoo Google what is your take
on that do you think the Chinese are
going to succeed in raising this cyber
wall I have come for reactions to the
whole Google story and I first shame on
Google shame on Google shame on
Microsoft shame on Yahoo for not
standing up more for certain basic
principles of human rights number one
number two well I say on the other hand
maybe we should take the high road keep
our eye on the prize yes in China today
you can at Google search for tenements
square or Falun Gong but you can still
search for Thomas Jefferson you can
still search for Ben Franklin isn't
isn't that what's really important if
95% of my searches you know will go
through isn't that what's really
important my third reaction is on the
other hand shame on China
after all if I'm a Chinese graduate
student in physics and I've got about to
graduate from the University of
Minnesota got a job offer at 3m I've got
a job offer at Huawei back in Shanghai
and I pick up the paper one day and I
see I can't search what I think I made
this
this 3m offer is looking a lot better in
Minnesota so I think this could bite
China in the bottom fourthly and lastly
I'm asking myself now I am finally on
the other other other hand is this the
end of something or the beginning of
something I think it's the end of
something I think it's the last gasp of
a security apparatus in China trying to
show that it's still relevant and
control something but to think that
you're gonna control the searches of 1.3
billion people oh good luck that is a
fool's errand well in terms of moving
bytes you can see that maybe the cyber
world will not succeed right
but moving atoms right there seems to be
again new of struggles coming up
recently as you know French government
has raised objection to the Indian owned
company acquiring the French steel
company our seller and mostly more
citizens in the United States that is a
pro because they do bio-port world is
going to acquire the management of six
American porks now this of course go
against the grain of free market that
the Western world upholds so how do you
square this on the one hand we uphold
free-market principles other hand we are
picking and choosing what countries
companies can buy in our country or not
I don't square at 9 what I look on it on
what I look at it is with huge
embarrassment I want to put a really
just skies on to think that our country
is part of this we believe in election
we believe in free markets I certainly
do we're not turning over our ports
security to Dubai Port Authority we're
turning the port authority in these six
ports over to people will say park their
park there collect the fees and whatnot
and manage the traffic in the port but
they're not going to be inspecting or
not inspecting cartons they're not going
to be bringing their cousins from Dubai
you know
in to infiltrate you know container
ships and I think it's a shameful and
and has actually slightly racist
overtones to it this is about keeping a
bunch of a rabs out of our country
that's really you know what it's about
and I think it's it's a bad thing not
because not only because it it doesn't
really reflect our real values that's
bad enough but this can start a tit for
tat
think of how many service operations
around the world around the Arab world
we run American companies I think what
an IBM is running or a FedEx is running
our UPS is running four companies around
the world
what what if they then turn around and
say well you're not going to take ours
well we're not going to take yours and
we're a very dangerous tit-for-tat
that could get going here this is a
really critical moment and we need to be
very careful about this so I think
although the world has not been used yet
a subtext of all this era owned company
is Muslim oh absolutely
that is unspoken subjects that I fear
might also don't have a real it's it's
it's part of the very dangerous backlash
that's going on both sides are guilty of
it I mean when when when people you know
ransack a Danish Embassy you know in
Damascus and the government allows it
you know governments are there in order
to restrain people's worst impulses well
we we have nativists in our country they
have nativists in their country that are
always going to want to push these kind
of extremist government's job is to
restrain that and I think this is a
really shameful episode and I think the
president's right on this one and I
don't agree with him on much but I agree
with him on this and the and the other
thing that is also becoming somewhat
questionable is the West's commitment to
democracy we support democracy but then
when the Palestinians elect Hamas let's
think about you know what what do you
say to those who are saying no Hamas is
a terrorist organization and should not
be supported
I think Hamas is a terrorist
organization but I also think it won a
free and fair election and if it's going
to be out
or if it's going to be um d legitimized
that should be for Palestinians to
decide and by the way only if they do it
will it actually have its D legitimizing
effects or its moderating effects if we
said to Hamas tomorrow well you don't
get any money unless you sing Hatikvah
the Israeli national anthem okay and
then the next day said fine call Lord
Baal a they started singing Hatikvah
would you believe them not I wouldn't
believe them okay then I might say well
you've got to sing at eeek fun perfect
kiddush standing on one leg pulling your
ear I still wouldn't believe them so why
ask people to do things that even if
they do them you wouldn't you wouldn't
believe them why not ask them to do
something that's really hard that you
would believe and that is maintain a
ceasefire with Israel oh that speaks to
me so much more than any words okay if
Hamas is ready to do that if they're
ready to allow the Palestinian Authority
to continue in a dialogue of
negotiations with Israel isn't that
what's really important you know we were
saying in journalism 9 as you know never
be smarter than the story you know when
the story is speaking to you shut up and
listen okay because you know all the
stories I get wrong were when I was
talking when I should have been
listening with this story speaking to us
so why don't we just shut up okay and
let's listen to what it says that's what
Palestinians say let's see how a mosque
behaves when they have the burden of
responsibility and if their deeds are
consonant with our interests that's what
matters not their words yeah the other
kind of broader implication of course is
the Hamas victory is how this be played
by the regime's in place in Middle East
who are being pressed to democratize are
they going to succeed in telling the
West look this is what happens if you
push for democracy so what should I mean
the response the response should be that
is what they will tell us but I guess
the response would be guys for 50 years
you've been telling us it's you or the
mosque you know all you aerobatic rats
have been telling is either one or the
deluge well you know what
the deluge anyways it's called 911 all
right when and and and it was called 7-7
and we keep getting the deluge in part
of the reason we get into deluge is
because you keep producing more of these
people with your authoritarianism
saying you know what we tried that for
50 years we'll give this a try for a
couple of years that's my attitude so
and you are prepared to accept I'm ready
to prepare to stomach Brotherhood yes I
am wincing [ __ ] you don't go from
Saddam to Jefferson without going
through home a knee in the Arab world
because there's nothing between the
palace and the mosque no civil society
at all so when the palace breaks either
by election or invasion you go straight
into freefall and we have to accept
that's the reality so you got two
choices then preserve the palace as
we've been for 50 years knowing that's
actually creating a context that's
actually producing more of these angry
frustrated unemployed young men or just
say you know what let's try to
liberalize the mosque once it has the
burden of responsibility
who knows how they'll behave and so if I
have to have a choice these days man
that's what I'm gonna go for there's
much I regret about how the Iraq war was
fought but the basic gut feeling that we
need to bust open that world because the
terrible bargain at the core that world
which is dictators basically blessing
retrograde religious leaders and those
religious leaders and blessing the
regime the regime blesses them with
money and title they bless the regime in
absence of a popular vote and it's a
perfect little closed-loop they got
going which produces frustrated angry
undereducated young people that hasn't
worked it's been a failure and I don't
see any liberalizing trend to it at all
okay and so I think it's time we try
something new and lastly how do you see
Iraq situation evolving I don't know you
know what worries me 9 is that that we
may be too late
I don't know we made so many mistakes
there that is just what I worry about is
that it may be too late that the boy
of ethnic division is now so much into
the bloodstream of Iraq ethnic and
sectarian to say exactly ethnic
religious sectarian division that it's
going to be impossible to ever really
build anything there that's what I worry
about today the explosion of the mosques
today I think was a horrible story and
you know let's put let's just finish
down by putting that explosion of the
mosque which is a micro and the whole
porch story together well no one's
blowing up our ports or what not but but
what they both do is inject that poison
the poison of division of sectarianism
you know of I want you know I want you
dead or I want you away from me
that's really dangerous because when
that starts you just don't know where
it's going to stop and this happening in
a flatter aware movement is so much
easier and individuals are empowered
exactly people hear it so much quicker
it's creating it's very worrying it's
very worrying when I think of how you or
I could have traveled the world and did
20 years ago when we first met in Hong
Kong the ease a carefree way we travel
and now the 10 things you have to think
of before you get your passport stamped
it's really disturbing ok Tom thanks
very much pleasure as always man thank
you thank you